voyage depuis cinq ans le club du 21e
siècle travail pour la reconnaissance
des minorités au sein des entreprises
publiques et privées
aujourd'hui l'organiser à paris des
rencontres avec des lycéens et le monde
du travail leur volonté donner une autre
image de l'immigration alors qu'est ce
que tout cela veut dire reportage
estelle cola et mathieu renier quitté la
banlieue pour les quartiers huppés de la
capitale pour les meilleurs d'entre eux
c'est le début de l'aventuré enfants
d'immigrés issus de minorités ou de
familles défavorisées
il était aujourd'hui un millier venus de
lycées difficiles à fouler le sol de
sciences po
charlotte bonne élève d'un lycée de
banlieue est venue accompagnée de sa
mère dans sa famille personne ne lui a
jamais parlé de ces filières d'exception
j'ai jamais abordé le sujet avec ma
famille j'ai même pas vers quel métier
ça aboutit c'est vraiment quelque chose
de vide
je connais rien je ne savais pas trop ce
que voulait dire h au sénat
or le mans la maison donc en même temps
c'est vraiment quelque chose que je peux
les pèse plus qu'on n'en parle pas face
à elle l'élite des chefs d'entreprises
banquiers entrepreneurs aux
fonctionnaires phone 7 coréenne arrivé
en france à l'âge de 6 mois
énarque un modèle de réussite physique
nous avons cette initiative parce que
nous sommes très favorables à la
méritocratie est très attaché au mieux
et au cra 6000 pensons que l'accès aux
dispositifs et aux mécanismes de
promotion sociale
elle n'est pas égal n'est pas également
assurer toutes les franges de la
population
le but aller chercher les talents là où
ils sont ils compris de l'autre côté du
périphérique astria 20 ans originaire du
congo termine sa première année à
sciences po
une fierté pour sa famille cette
occasion s'est présentée ni bon pour pas
à laisser croatie ou la saisie aller
jusqu'au bout ces face à face ont fait
leurs preuves
l'amphithéâtre de sciences politiques
depuis 2001 a accueilli sur ses beaux
quelque 600 élèves de quartiers
défavorisés